something interesting gooby with with
canning love your thoughts kansas city
six innings one run three starts ago at
oakland five innings two runs so that
was two starts ago at tampa five innings
two earned runs he's pitched a lot
better of late why yeah because he's
been able to attack the strike zone and
when he when he uses his fastball more
he gets in that position where that
change up usage has gone up and slider
eugene's going down a bit losing his
curveball more but i love the fact that
he's trusting his fastball big shift
defensively for cedric mullins to start
it rendon is on the grass it's a pretty
good company and anthony rendon we told
you he was on the grass for a reason
well he made a lot of outstanding plays
when we go back to that victory in new
york that comeback victory it was about
three or four plays during the course of
that game where anthony and rodol made
some outstanding plays at third base
going to the backhand this time he's got
to go glove side dives out knowing how
quick mullins get down he's got 15
stolen baits a good guy to keep off the
bases showing that range for rendon and
that's a time where he's been diving
that's where he's hurt that shoulder
would it dive on an extension like that
was a real good play by anthony rendon
two down for trey and the count is even
trey mancini with a drive deep into
center field this is good
his first home run
since being named to the home run derby
and we might see a whole lot of that in
a couple of weeks in colorado number 15
for trey
to jolt the orioles in front 4 51
is the distance off the bat and that is
some major power that was large and the
sound it made coming off the bet you
knew it was a no-doubter right at 110
miles an hour and watch this swing
two-strike swing swing and a mistake by
canning a fastball at 94 and watch this
trey mancini puts everything he got into
this one and gets every stitch of this
baseball to the straightaway center
field for his 15th large win of the year
run so keegan aiken will certainly have
his hands full tonight didn't make the
club out of spring training went down
and was recalled and when he came up
made some relief appearances and been in
the rotation his first three starts were
really good his last three starts have
not been as good for him hopped up right
side foul ground mount castle does he
have room yes he does on the foul
warning track he puts it away
and there's one going well here is the
biggest show in baseball right now
the major league home run leader with 28
reigning american league player of the
month
he could hit a ball harder run faster
and throw harder than anybody else but
joey o'donnell but that was a really
good pitch by aiken got right in on the
hands he broke that bat of ohtani and
here's keegan against with percentage
you can see the fastball right at 21 but
the change up as well for him 30 percent
the slider 25 percent with percentage so
has to get ahead with a fastball then
expand his own with the off speed stuff
and when keegan aiken does that he can
be very effective well two pitches two
outs is pretty brilliant now jared walsh
a ground ball to first mount castle has
it takes it and ends the unit a
scoreless inning for keegan aiken
including a pop out against show a
ohtani oh is in front after one at the
big end domingo laban now batter with
two down this is an eight-pitch half-bat
to laba and he golfs one into right
field ward is back and this ball is gone
domingo laba has his first major league
home run the orioles have gone deep
twice tonight mancini in the first and
now labor in the second his first home
run is a big leaguer and it comes at the
big a that was a nice swing 3-2 breaking
ball and watch leyva sink into his legs
on this one he recognized this one right
out of the hand instead of getting that
weight forward watch him sink right
there just sinks into his leg and simply
drops a barrel on that slider
kind of middle middle down part right
where a lot of lefties like it you can
see the breaking ball spinning watch him
sink right there
love that approach and this was a no
doubter clearly well over the 365.
iglesias he was trying to tie the game
up counts owen two here's the pitch he
does give that one a ride toward the
corner it goes by
home run number seven for iglesias iggy
getting iggy with it ties it up against
his former team showing the power
seventh home run 26.
rbi totals iglesias that's in the power
tying it up just like that and the
orioles have two singles in a walk all
with two outs to load the bases for
anthony santander
that ball is ripped and a fair ball this
is going to find the wall and score at
least two hayes and mancini mount castle
coming around he is safe
bring them all home
unloads the bases on a three-run double
and the orioles are back in front in a
big way
seventh batter of the inning after a
quick two outs against valencia and
mullins single single walk and a double
a one
severino to left field and severino will
bring in a run
santander is going to come home back to
back doubles in the inning it's six to
two
as the o's are pouring it on in the
third
did so much damage in the month of june
the player of the month in the american
league ops 13 12 13 home runs for show
hey otani labels on the cut of the grass
at third big ship defensively let's take
a ride
with another show hey hover boy you knew
he was going to do something special
today ale player of the month selected
to his first all-star game at shohei
just missed it last bat did not miss it
at this at bat for shohei ohtani 29th
home run 64. rbi show me the money on
that swing 2-2
max got that breaking ball lines it into
left field for a base hit they're going
to send rendon oh what a throw to the
plate the slide safe at the plate hayes
came up with the beauty and anthony slid
right around the tag it's 6-4 kate is
ready here's the pitch
ledge
through the wickets rbi for david mr
risk yes it is comes through again so
clutch with runners in scoring position
nobody better here's shohei 6'5
[Applause]
i've never seen anything like this power
right center
power left field and he knew it off the
bat
second home run of the game wow must see
tv every minute of every day shohei oh
tony just like that the halos are up 7-6
angels up 7-6 in the bottom of the fifth
inning and spencer watkins is in making
his mlb debut you see he did triple a
with the orioles mostly a starter
one and two record a very good era
making his major league debut and i'm
gonna tell you i remember mine it's like
you're floating running in from the from
the bullpen he was almost in tears a
couple of days ago talking about how
close he came to stepping away
almost became a coach at paradise valley
high school in phoenix he was going to
take over the freshman team if you
didn't get a chance
he's got a chance
and he's got a fly ball to right
spencer watkins has a major league era
and it's 0.00
after a flyout from taylor ward
on the second day of july 2021 welcome
to the bigs austin hayes a right-handed
battery hey smacks one this will tie the
game into left center that gets all the
way to the wall pass gosselin hayes into
second base he'll hold right there
an rbi double for austin hayes he powers
the orioles into a tie game seven up in
the sixth
well how about you austin hayes huh you
talk about put a barrel on one 1-0 count
he's hunting a fastball he gets one
middle middle at 90 miles an hour and he
quickly finds a barrel this is a line
drive out toward left center field 108
off the bat it gets all the way to the
wall cedric mullins comes home ties this
game at seven there is two outs here has
not allowed a home run this year
paul frye joe hayes going again throw
down he swiped that one
safe is the call
there's your winning run elite speed
walsh the batter the counts want to know
he's gone over four tonight maybe save
the best for last
and the angels come away with a victory
walk-off style